certains disent monsieur votre président
vladimir poutine est devenu fou qu'est
ce que vous leur répondez ces gens sont
fous peut-être c'est pas lui pourquoi il
est devenu fou le président qui protège
son propre pays qui veut assurer la
sécurité pour son propre pays pourquoi
il faut penser qu'il peut avoir raison
contre le reste du monde
le reste du monde se trompe on savait
restaurateurs déformé afep équipementier
allemand puma qui a décidé de fermer
plus de 100 magasins dans le pays une
décision promu crânienne pas du goût du
rappeur booba égérie de la marque depuis
novembre 2020 vous rompez je romps si
vous faites de la politique nous devons
en faire aussi mais sachez qu'en cas
d'agression la riposte sera là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toutes celles qui rendent
moi je trouve que c'est pas du tout le
boss c'est pas du tout le duc je trouve
que c'est juste un pleutre qui à miami
qui nous donne des leçons dont je trouve
que c'est dégueulasse parce que
aujourd'hui on est en guerre et on est
soit avec soit contrée ya pas tergiversé
attendre d'eux comme ça et pardon mais
booba a toujours fait de la politique
tout ce qu'il fait et géraldine ils nous
donnent aucune leçon de civisme elysées
son communiqué vous savez je n'ai pas
signé pour ça ni aucune leçon non mais
booba ne fait que de la politique est-ce
que vous soutenez cette guerre monsieur
le porte parole au fond de vous vous
savez c'est pas une guerre c'est une
opération militaire et si cette
opération militaire est destinée à
assurer la sécurité de nos propres pays
et non seulement de mon pays mais dont
le crâne aussi et de tout le continent
européen mais bien sûr je soutiens cette
opération mais c'est une guerre c'est
pas une guerre montrent un sens c'est
une guerre c'est pas eu l'air sinon
donald trump a proposé ce week-end de
bombarder la russie mais avec des avions
déguisé aux couleurs de la chine le
washington post a dû préciser ce matin
que c'était évidemment illégal de
bombarder la russie avec des drapeaux
chinois pas sûr que poutine se serait
risqué à attaquer l'ukraine avec trump
au pouvoir
en guerre parce que quand on part de la
guerre ça en ce sens à un peu plus
générale plus globale mais on cible pas
les civils on savait aussi bhl
uniquement les éléments néo nazis et les
éléments de l'armée ukrainienne qui
continuent leurs résidents manifestement
des enfants vous considérez comme des
néo nazis en ukraine merci monsieur est
revenue hanter les matches parce que
c'est la guerre
parce qu'il est difficile de se projeter
dans le futur
lydia et valérie ont décidé de se marier
une cérémonie orthodoxe organisait le
temps d'une accalmie sur les lignes de
front avec kaki et casques lourds je
vous déclare mari et femme oui vous
pouvez les féliciter alors écoute elodie
paraît que les femmes auraient un
sixième sens pour sentir les choses
avant quand vous le disent alors essaye
de deviner
les désirs de ton époux puis toi franck
fais comme tu veux
[Musique]
à
à partir de 30 ans tout homme en couple
sait très bien que c'est madame qui
l'habille c'est après l'arrivée c'est ma
théorie je vous dis
tu large que ça c'est à dire clairement
c'est madame qui a choisi les prénoms
des enfants le seul choix qui me restent
aujourd'hui c'est le choix du modèle de
voiture à ce conducteur pressé tentent
une manoeuvre pour le moins audacieux 7
j essaie de croiser un bus sur une
petite route au brésil afin d'accéder à
la plage
elle roule avec deux roues contre le
flanc d'une falaise mais cela ne se
passe pas comme prévu
[Musique]
les occupants sont obligés de s'extirper
du véhicule
il aurait mieux valu prendre son mal en
patience
voici donc la liste des douze candidates
et candidats à l'élection présidentielle
telle qu'elle a été arrêtée par le
conseil constitutionnel
nathalie arthaud
fabien roussel
emmanuel macron jean lassalle
marine le pen eric zemmour jean luc
mélenchon
années
voilà pardon donc pour ce petit problème
technique pas d'attitude ça veut dire
qu'on est en retard sur un temps de
parole des candidats sur qui jean
lassalle ok on lui doit combien
d'accords voici donc 10 secondes de
temps de parole pour jean lassalle tkm
tokai tokyo
quant aux permis aux qu'ayant presse des
yo et sa comptant le printemps s'est
enfui de filons temps déjà craint que
les feuilles mortes brûlées les feux de
bois à voir par ici beau dans cette fin
d'automne soudain je mal anguilles rêve
je frissonne jeu tant que je chavire et
comme la rengaine je vais je bien je
viens je tourne et je vais traîne ton
image menthe
je te parle tout bas et j'ai le mal
d'amour et j'ai le mal de toi
je sais que beaucoup s'interrogent
sur le choix qui est aujourd'hui le
moins le mien mes chers amis le temps
est venu de transformer nos espoirs où
est passée aujourd'hui notre rêve
français somme modique somme non d'où
son nom me perturber
sommes nous on va mettre ça sur le
compte du stress vous dit j'en ai marre
d'être pris pour un bouseux pour un cul
terreux je ne suis pas ce à quoi je
devrais dire je supplie pour pour un
client
c'est à dire je suis totalement tenu à
l'écart
le monde politique
et puis par les médias et jours la salle
on le disait la semaine dernière est le
seul candidat à faire le paquito au
salon de l'agriculture mais il est
également le seul candidat a le
débriefer et l'analyser sur lci sur ce
gain
il faut combiner vous êtes bienvenus oui
parce que c'est bon
yann le floch
a des gars là vont passer au dessus
comment on fait pour gainer
et
bombay du seul ps la présentation était
super jolie je me suis retrouvé un peu à
bali en thaïlande puisque j'ai déjà
voyagé
[Musique]
ben ali en thaïlande ben ali c'est en
indonésie soria vous savez à 5600
kilomètres de bangkok les influenceurs
nous avait habitués à nous vendre tout
et n'importe quoi fut de resserrement
intime mais on a encore passé un lebel
au dessus avec ruby nient caral
influence au dos 690 mille abonnés sur
tik tok
suisse
elle a en effet lancé un site pour
vendre l'eau de son bain
non vous ne rêvez pas 1500 euros le nid
plus cher qu'un magnum de champagne
j'aime trop l'argent non mais là je
crois que là là c'est la débandade vous
rembourser le crédit avec les loyers ça
bah voilà ça c'est super lapierre ya qu
il ya que ça de vrai parce que vous
n'êtes pas très bitcoins et j'ai
l'impression trop voilà il a préféré
investir dans la pierre ricaud kevin des
pardons là on a une blague de mettre
notre vie particulièrement gênant